bonjour david lescot les manifestants
sont pour rendez vous effectivement ce
fils ont répondu présent pour répondre à
la provocation du gouvernement
le mot d'ordre de cette mobilisation le
déni de la démocratie
beaucoup de manifestants ont jugé
l'attitude inacceptable en d'edouard
philippe samedi devant l'assemblée
nationale pour annoncer ce recours aux
49 3 vis-à-vis de la réforme des
retraites une attitude inacceptable et
tous les corps des métiers sont
représentés dans ce dans ce cortège pour
dénoncer cette ce passage en force de la
loi
le pont pour la réforme des retraites je
vous propose d'écouter a real esteli à
présidente du syndicat des avocats de
france et il veut verrier secrétaire de
force ouvrière qui dénonce l'attitude du
gouvernement
la bataille continue elle n'est pas
perdu le 49 3 ne fait que repousser le
débat qui continuera devant les
sénateurs puis de nouveau devant
l'assemblée nationale
et enfin le conseil constitutionnel sera
saisi il déclarera inconstestablement un
certain nombre de dispositions de ce
texte contraire à la constitution donc
il faut rester mobilisés ce gouvernement
un problème de dialogue
en réalité il a des lubies il porte une
réforme dogmatique il n'a pas de
réponses aux questions qu'on lui pose
notamment sur la valeur du point et donc
ils préfèrent se servir de cette
épidémie pour faire diversion et pas
répondre aux questions fondamentales qui
se posent dans ce projet de loi je pense
très sincèrement que c'est aussi un
mauvais coup pour le gouvernement
je pense qu'il a fait une grave erreur
du point de vue de l'opinion publique ça
n'est pas cela qu'on attendait ce n'est
pas cela je pense que la plupart des
français qui sont inquiets par rapport à
l'épidémie attendait notre objectif est
d'afficher d' affirmer très clairement
que nous ne baisse pas les bras qu'on ne
reste pas spectateur pourquoi parce que
nous sommes convaincus que nous avons
raison nous sommes convaincus de nos
raisons nous sommes convaincus nos
analyses jamais nous n'avons été
contredit jusqu'à maintenant le 31 mars
nouveau temps fort de grève
interprofessionnelle de manifestations
parce qu'on sait qu'on sera à
mi-parcours du débat parlementaire on le
savait quoi qu'il en serait de 49 3 ou
pas donc rendez-vous aussi le 31 mars
l'intersyndicale et
l'interprofessionnelle ont répondu
présent pour cette mobilisation contre
ce 49,3 en pis vous l'aurez compris en
tout cas la mobilisation va se
poursuivre durant tout le mois de mars
en tout cas pour cette journée assez
particulière la première juste après le
recours aux 49 3 les manifestants ont
répondu présent un important dispositif
de sécurité a été mis en place autour du
cortège
didier lallement a prévu de mettre tous
les moyens matériels et humains pour
éviter toute violence et tout
débordement
l'atout de violences et débordements qui
n'ont pas lieu pour le moment puisque la
manifestation se passe dans le calme et
de manière très pacifique et on suivra
avec vous c'est une mobilisation un
compte à leur merci à david un califat